Новини дня «Heute» з Яною Парайґіс.
Добрий вечір усім.
Про неймовірний фінал Ліги Європи
сьогодні розповість Катя Штрезо.
Головні теми випуску:
вітер як джерело енергії.
Упродовж наступних десятиліть
Європа планує збільшити
кількість вітроелектричних установок
поблизу європейського узбережжя у 20 разів.
Через лобіювання інтересів Путіна ексканцлер
Німеччини потрапив у скрутне становище:
«світлофорна» коаліція позбавила
Герхарда Шредера офісу та інших привілеїв.
«Вторгнення» фанів у Андалусію.
Перед фіналом Ліги Європи,
у якому відбудеться поєдинок
між Франкфуртом та Глазго,
Севілья опинилася у надійних
руках німців та шотландців.
Як позбутися залежності від
російських газу та нафти?
Це одне із головних питань з початку
російського вторгнення в Україну.
ЄС хоче припинити фінансування
«військової машини» Путіна.
ЄС виділить 300 млрд євро
для розбудови джерел відновлюваної енергії.
Очільники урядів Німеччини, Данії, Бельгії та Нідерландів
сьогодні обговорювали використання вітроенергетики.
У саміті на узбережжі Північного моря, що відбувся
у данському місті Есб’єрг, також взяла участь
президентка Єврокомісії Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
Данія - взірець у галузі вітроенергетики.
Невелика країна, розташована
між Балтійським та Північним морями,
вже зараз покриває майже половину
своїх потреб в електроенергії
завдяки енергії вітру.
У Німеччині цей показник становить близько 23%,
а у ЄС - 14%.
Зараз саме час змінити ситуацію.
До 2050 року ЄС планує вдвічі збільшити
потужність своїх морських вітроелектростанцій.
Детальніше про це розповість Анне Геллінек.
Звичайно, не випадково саме сьогодні уряд Данії
запросив європейських лідерів
на так званий саміт «вітру»,
що відбувся на узбережжі Північного моря.
Серед запрошених - канцлер Німеччини Олаф Шольц
та президентка Єврокомісії Урсула фон дер Ляєн.
Вітроелектростанції сприятимуть вирішенню
енергетичної кризи у Європі,
яка загострилася після вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Зрозуміло, що ми повинні досягти
енергетичної незалежності від Росії
якомога швидше. До того ж набагато швидше,
ніж ми планували до початку війни.
Шлях до такої незалежності Єврокомісія вбачає
у надшвидкій розбудові відновлюваних джерел енергії.
До 2030 року вони повинні виробляти
не 40%, а 45% усієї енергії у Європі.
Для цього необхідно значно
полегшити процедури ухвалення.
Навіть у такому разі ЄС зможе покрити
потреби в електроенергії
завдяки вітроелектростанціям лише через дев'ять років.
Необхідно також сприяти розвитку сонячної енергетики,
встановлюючи сонячні панелі на дахи будинків.
З 2026 року такі панелі обов`язково мають бути на
новобудовах громадського призначення,
а з 2029 року - на приватних будинках.
Загалом представники промисловості
підтримують цей задум,
проте чи можливо його реалізувати?
На жаль, завеликі амбіції - характерна ознака
європейських підходів до політики.
Спершу політики прагнуть досягти
нереалістичних цілей,
втім, ніхто не знає, як це зробити,
як правильно втілити плани
та як відбуватиметься цей процес.
Самих лише цілей недостатньо.
Для поставок зрідженого газу та водню
Єврокомісія пропонує створити
своєрідне закупівельну спілку,
щоб європейські країни не конкурували між собою.
За підрахунками Єврокомісії, для
реорганізації енергетичної галузі
необхідно близько 300 млрд євро.
На це витратять кошти з бюджету ЄС та прибуток
від торгівлі квотами на викиди парникових газів.
Втім, спершу потрібно отримати згоду
усіх країн-членів ЄС та Європарламенту.
Тож Європа розробляє план для
енергопостачання у майбутньому,
який передбачає відмову від російської енергетики.
Проте як це зробити?
Ще більше цікавої інформації з цієї теми та інтерв'ю
з міністром економіки Габеком шукайте
у наших соцмережах та застосунку ZDFheute.
Поговорімо про ситуацію в Україні.
Згідно із російськими даними, з блокадного
заводу «Азовсталь» капітулювали
ще сотні українських військових.
Що ж насправді з ними відбувається?
Наш кореспондент Томас Гонзіор
зараз перебуває в Україні
і свій репортаж про 84 день війни
він розпочне з Маріуполя.
Перед вами - бійці полку «Азов».
Позаду них - металургійний завод
та довгі дні у його підвалах.
Попереду - довгі дні у російському полоні.
Ймовірно, це будуть дні, повні страху.
Адже ніхто не знає, яка доля їх спіткає.
В Україні вони справжні герої.
Один із бійців «Азову» - друг Дар'ї Цикунової.
Вона у безпеці, втім не може впоратися
із хвилюванням.
Неважливо, як сильно я ним пишаюся.
Адже йому досі загрожує смертельна небезпека.
Серед полонених - і чоловіки, і жінки.
Згідно з російськими даними, капітулювали
ще близько 700 військових.
У Маріуполі все більше націоналістів здаються в полон.
З понеділка капітулювало близько 1000 полонених,
з них - 80 поранених.
Київ не підтверджує ані ці показники,
ані капітуляцію.
За словами української сторони, це -
скоординована рятувальна операція.
Евакуаційна місія з «Азовсталі» триває.
Нею керують наші військові та розвідка.
Також залучені найвпливовіші міжнародні посередники.
Мета місії - обмін полоненими.
Москва відмовляється.
Військове протистояння триває й надалі.
На Донбасі, у місті Соледар, окупанти обстріляли
підприємство німецького виробника гіпсокартону «Knauf».
З початку війни завод призупинив діяльність,
тож людей у будівлі не було.
Незрозуміло, хто саме здійснив напад.
На Заході, поблизу міста Львів,
російська армія завдала авіаударів.
Міський голова зазначає, що у такий спосіб
Москва намагається залякати гуманітарні організації.
У Києві сьогодні відбувся перший суд
над російським військовим за скоєні воєнні злочини.
Цього 21-річного росіянина звинувачують у вбивстві
цивільного українця на Північному Сході,
поблизу міста Суми.
Він визнав свою провину, тож тепер
йому загрожує довічне ув'язнення.
Він хоча б знає, чого чекати, а ось
бійці «Азову», які потрапили у полон до росіян, - ні.
Наш кореспондент Йоганнес Гано зараз
перебуває в Україні, у передмісті Києва.
Тож майже 1000 бійців з металургійного заводу
«Азовсталь» зараз - у російському полоні.
Що може з ними статися?
Усе залежить лише від Володимира Путіна.
Він завжди хотів взяти у полон
щонайбільше бійців полку «Азов»,
щоб судити їх та довести, що вони нацисти,
від яких він звільняє Україну.
Питання полягає у тому, в яких злочинах їх
звинуватять та де саме.
Державна дума Росії ухвалила закон, який класифікує
ці підрозділи як терористичну організацію.
Тож тепер бійців полку можуть
судити без доказів скоєння воєнних злочинів.
Усе залежить від того, де відбудеться суд.
Якщо у Росії, то їм загрожує довічне ув'язнення.
Якщо ж у маріонеткових
республіках Росії ДНР чи ЛНР,
їх чекатиме смертна кара, а саме - розстріл.
Це найтрагічніший можливий
сценарій цієї «капітуляції».
Адже президент України наказав своїм військовим
здатися, щоб запобігти вірної смерті
на території цього металургійного заводу.
Доля бійців «Азову» буде трагічною,
якщо їх таки судитимуть і розстріляють.
Дякую.
Через загрозу з боку Росії
Швеції та Фінляндії довелося відмовитися
від нейтралітету, якого вони
дотримувалися впродовж десятиліть.
Сьогодні обидві країни офіційно
подали заявку на вступ у НАТО.
Їхні посли надали Генеральному секретарю НАТО
Столтенбергу необхідні документи.
Власне, країни-члени НАТО хотіли розпочати
переговори щодо вступу.
Однак президент Туреччини Ердоган
заблокував це рішення.
На одному із засідань партії він
зажадав від Швеції та Фінляндії
спершу видати кількох курдів,
яких вважає терористами.
Здається, що Туреччина дійсно
не збирається йти на поступки.
Флоріан Нойганн, така позиція
не влаштовує НАТО, чи не так?
Авжеж, ні.
Позиція Туреччини зіпсувала святковий настрій
цього ранку, коли були подані заявки на вступ.
З одного боку, багато хто стверджує,
що цього варто було очікувати
з огляду на досить різку риторику Анкари
впродовж останніх декількох днів.
З іншого боку, блокування вступу показує союзникам,
що ставки Ердогана дуже високі.
Окрім того, президент Туреччини піддає ризику
головних союзників Заходу.
НАТО зараз цілком покладається на кризову дипломатію.
Сьогодні у Нью-Йорку для обговорення цього питання
зустрінуться держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен
та міністр закордонних справ Туреччини Чавушоглу.
Дипломати переконані, що
Туреччина не вставлятиме палиці в колеса.
Інший сценарій може стати катастрофою для НАТО.
Адже це означатиме крах єдності,
яку Альянс демонструє впродовж останніх тижнів.
Це так само було б сигналом перемоги.
Принаймні для однієї людини -
російського президента Володимира Путіна.
Дякую.
Через війну в Україні чимало людей,
перш за все з бідних країн, перебувають
під загрозою масового голоду.
Як можна покращити ситуацію?
На засіданні міністрів економічного
розвитку країн «Великої сімки»
у Берліні міністерка Німеччини Шульце
запропонувала створити альянс з
глобальної продовольчої безпеки.
Це дозволить швидко надати необхідну допомогу.
Через кліматичну кризу також потрібно
забезпечити сталість сільського господарства.
Зв`язок ексканцлера Шредера
з російським президентом Путіним
впродовж тривалого часу викликає неоднозначну реакцію.
Зараз Шредер вимушений зіткнутися
із опосередкованими наслідками цієї дружби.
Шредер обіймав посаду канцлера з
1998 до 2005 року та очолював
червоно-зелену коаліцію. Ще тоді Шредер
добре знав російського президента.
Згодом він працював над проєктом
«Північного потоку», обіймав посади
у російській компанії «Gazprom» та
енергетичному концерні «Rosneft».
Війна в Україні не мала жодних
наслідків для Шредера.
Однак зараз він втратить усі привілеї ексканцлера.
Детальніше - у сюжеті
Ларса Бонзака та Андреаса Гупперта.
Впродовж останніх років у ньому вбачали лише
лобіста російських енергетичних компаній.
Герхард Шредер дуже рідко, або й взагалі ніколи,
не прибував із візитом як ексканцлер Німеччини.
Тепер це коштуватиме йому таких привілеїв
як офіс та персонал.
Зараз ми вважаємо,
що персонал та офіс надаються
до тих пір, поки ви виконуєте посадові обов'язки.
Якщо ви цього не робите,
ви не отримуєте офіційного устаткування.
Офіс ексканцлера коштував державі
приблизно 400 000 євро на рік.
Політики з держбюджету навмисно не згадують
про контакти Шредера з Росією
та війну в Україні.
Це стосується не тільки Шредера,
а й всіх ексканцлерів.
Ми, працівники держбюджету,
дбаємо про гроші платників податків
та говоримо, куди їх можна витрачати, а куди - ні.
Насправді союзCDU/CSU хотів піти далі
та скасувати пенсію Шредера.
Тепер вони погоджуються
із вимогою «світлофорної» коаліції.
Ситуація з Шредером досить особлива.
Він рішуче виступає проти
інтересів нашої країни.
І це має призвести до певних наслідків.
У такий спосіб він втратив право на
будь-які правові та моральні вимоги.
Ліві, з іншого боку,
стурбовані не лише Шредером.
Також ексканцлерка Ангелі Меркель
могла обійтися без дев'яти співробітників,
яких їй було дозволено,
з відповідними офісами.
Колишнім канцлерам
не потрібен суд
після їхнього терміну.
У Бундестазі можливо досягти домовленостей щодо
організації зустрічей
із широким загалом.
Однак це вийшло з-під контролю
і це потрібно зупинити.
Друг Путіна Шредер втратив свою репутацію
ще на початку війни.
Тепер його привілеї колишнього канцлера -
також у минулому.
Урок від пандемії коронавірусу:
сьогодні Кабінет міністрів Німеччини затвердив
надзвичайний механізм для надання виплат BAföG,
щоб мати можливість
підтримувати студентів у кризових ситуаціях.
Максимальна виплата BAföG з осені становитиме
809 євро на місяць.
Що приблизно відображає
середню вартість життя
для студентів.
Але цього недостатньо,
особливо у великих містах на Заході Німеччини.
В середньому кімнати в комунальних квартирах
коштують 414 євро на місяць,
в Мюнхені, який очолює рейтинг за цим показником, -
навіть 680 євро.
І точно не всі отримують допомогу BAföG.
З майже трьох млн студентів
близько 466 тис. мають право на BAföG.
Тим, хто підробляє в кафе чи має інший підробіток,
було скрутно під час пандемії.
Репортаж Романа Лесковара.
Луне Гротер навчається в Гамбурзі
та бере участь у роботі Вільної асоціації
студентських спілок.
Вона добре знає потреби однокурсників.
Екзистенційні страхи через втрату роботи
за умов пандемії або проблеми з виплатою BAföG.
Під час навчання на бакалавраті вона отримала 300 євро.
Звісно, на цю суму неможливо прожити.
Я отримувала допомогу на дитину
і завжди працювала неповний робочий день.
З тими грошима, які я мала,
я точно була за межою бідності
в перші кілька семестрів.
Згідно з аналізом, проведеним Паритетним союзом
(Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband),
30% студентів в Німеччині
нині страждають від бідності.
Їхній середній дохід
становить 802 євро.
Водночас дедалі менше студентів
отримують виплати BAföG.
Той факт, що лише 11% студентів
взагалі отримують допомогу BAföG
за рівня бідності 30%
вказує на хибність системи.
Тож її потрібно реформувати,
щоб справді зробити BAföG
придатним відповідати на виклики бідності.
Федеральний уряд тим часом
представив плани
щодо реформи BAföG.
Це було винесено на сьогоднішнє обговорення
в освітньому комітеті.
Наприклад, максимальні виплати мають
збільшитися на 5%.
До того ж надбавка на оплату житла
має бути підвищена на 11% та скласти 360 євро.
Внаслідок пандемії планується додати
ще один постійний механізм для надзвичайних обставин,
який діятиме під час кризи:
тепер право на виплати від BAföG
отримають і ті студенти,
які раніше його не мали.
Наприклад, через перевищення
ліміту доходів їхніх батьків
або через зміну спеціальності.
Для Луне Гротер та її однокурсників -
це лише перший крок.
Для боротьби з бідністю серед студентів
потрібно зробити набагато більше.
Авіакатастрофа в Китаї
в березні минулого року
могла бути спричинена навмисно.
Про це повідомляє «Wall Street
Journal»,
посилаючись на дані бортового самописця,
які також були проаналізовані
американськими слідчими.
Так видання цитує джерело з кола слідчих:
«Літак зробив те,
як його було запрограмовано кимось у кабіні».
Мабуть, це був один з двох пілотів.
Літак раптово втратив висоту
під час внутрішнього рейсу,
потім майже вертикально врізався в землю.
Всі 132 особи на борту загинули.
Новий кліматичний звіт показує,
як тисне час.
Всесвітня організація погоди називає
чотири показники.
І всі вони в червоній зоні.
Концентрація парникових газів
в атмосфері на 149%
перевищила доіндустріальний рівень станом на 2020 рік.
Рівень моря зараз підвищується
на 4,5 міліметра на рік,
це вдвічі більше, ніж кілька років тому.
Крім того, вода в океанах з року в рік
стає теплішою і кислотнішою
і тому може утримувати все менше
додаткового CO2.
А тепер - про футбол.
Менш ніж за дві години
відбудеться головний матч,
на думку франкфуртського «Айнтрахт».
Фінал Ліги Європи
проти «Рейнджерс» із Глазго в
спекотній іспанській Севільї.
Йдеться про титул та
місце в майбутньому сезоні Ліги чемпіонів
і, звичайно, про здійснення великої мрії.
Дві групи вболівальників, одна думка.
Після десятиліть очікування Міжнародний титул
знову можуть здобути
або сині з Глазго, або білі з Франкфурта.
Це унікальне відчуття - бути тут.
«Айнтрахт» не зможе повторити це
в найближчі кілька десятиліть -
хоча мені цього хотілося б.
Але там потрібно просто бути.
Це наш кубок, наш.
Він ще нікому не належить.
Команда «Айнтрахта» також перебуває
в хорошому настрої.
Настає переможна ейфорія,
яка підживлюється вболівальниками.
Завжди присутні невимірні фактори,
і я думаю, що
ця підтримка є одним з них.
Іноді саме вона допомагає здобути перемогу.
150 тис. прихильників з обох таборів
перебувають у місті.
44 тис. людей
можуть розміститися на стадіоні.
У провулках Севільї очікуються натовпи.
Не тільки в самій Севільї
десятки тисяч вболівальників «Айнтрахта»
з нетерпінням чекають на гру.
У Франкфурті також зустрінуться приблизно
60 тис. глядачів
для перегляду матчу на стадіоні
та навколо нього.
Деякі з них пробираються з центру міста,
від ратуші «Рьомер», до стадіону.
Настрій вже ейфоричний.
Моя колега Клавдія Нойман -
зараз у Севільї.
Клавдія, йдеться про
50 тис. вболівальників «Айнтрахта»
і 100 тис. шотландських вболівальників.
Яка атмосфера на місці?
Гаряче в обох значеннях цього слова.
Тим часом напруга помітно зростає.
Через «ворожість» таборів
вболівальників двох команд було спрямовано
в окремі оточені коридори,
щоб уникнути сутичок.
Це особливий фінал.
Франкфуртський «Айнтрахт»
своїми чудовими виступами
сприяв покращенню іміджу німецьких команд.
Була відроджена іскра,
яка з різних причин
була втрачена під час пандемії.
Щоб залишитися в Бундеслізі або хоча б потрапити до неї,
іскра точно не завадить.
У медальній кузні Кієнбаума
«Герта» готується перейти в нижчу лігу.
У центрі уваги - Фелікс Магат.
Це суперечить його улюбленому клубу,
де він був гравцем і тренером.
Ні, дурниці.
Говорити зараз, що Гамбург - тепер суперник,
мені взагалі все одно.
Звичайно, це неправда,
але це тепер не відіграє жодної ролі.
У той час як «Герта»
нещодавно пропустила три м'ячі
і опинилася в зоні вильоту,
Гамбург під керівництвом тренера
Тіма Вальтера сповнений впевненості в собі.
Лише п’ять перемог поспіль
дали команді з Гамбурга шанс
прейти у вищу лігу.
Сьогодні середа, це означає, що
були розіграні лотерейні номери.
Виграшні номери: 8-10-25-41-43-45.
І суперчисло: 6.
Більше виграшних
номерів можна знайти на сайті lotto. zdf.de
та в ZDF Text на сторінці 557.
Завтра із заходу прийдуть сильні грози.
У п’ятницю також можлива
несприятлива погода.
Незабаром ви дізнаєтеся все, що вам потрібно
знати про це від Каті Горнеффер.
Крістіан Зіверс о 21:45 пропонує
вашій увазі випуск «Heute journal».
Завтра в ефірі з вами буде Митрі Зірін.
Я прощаюся з вами.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні був ще один день перепочинку,
але незабаром все зміниться.
Тому що з Південного заходу
все більше насувається непогода.
До нас прямує задушливе повітря.
Сьогодні цього ще не помітно,
а от завтра вже очікується тепла погода.
У великих містах Рурського регіону
температура не опускається нижче 20°.
Нічні температури в Баварії набагато приємніші -
від 10 до 8°.
Завтра буде спекотніше,
переважно з температурою від 26 до 31°.
І тільки біля Північного моря
буде трохи прохолодніше.
Завтра вранці в Емсленді
можлива перша гроза,
але зрештою буде сонячно.
Проте повітря буде задушливим.
Найпізніше в другій половині дня
пройдуть сильні грози.
Тут, у Саарі, в Рейнланд-Пфальці,
Північному Рейні-Вестфалії,
а також у Західній Нижній Саксонії,
а ввечері з Шварцвальда та Альп.
Йдеться про шторми
з поривами вітру до 100 км/год,
з сильними дощами
до 40 л на кв. м за короткий час
і градом з середнім розміром 3 см.
У п'ятницю ввечері пройдуть грози.
Наступні грози прийдуть в центральну частину.
Гарного вечора!